♪
>> Laura: AMOR INGRAHAM AND
THIS IS "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE" ON
A BUSY FRIDAY NIGHT SO WE ARE
GOING TO DIVE RIGHT INTO RADAR
VANISHING PRESIDENT, THAT IS TH
FOCUS OF TO MAKE ANGLE.
THERE MIGHT BE, AND I EMPHASIZE
MIGHT BE SOME GOOD NEWS
REGARDING THE RUSSIA UKRAINE
CRISIS TONIGHT.
THEY SAVED THE RUSSIA AND
UKRAINE ARE NEARING A PEACE DEAL
.
IN USING RUSSIAN AS AN OFFICIAL
LANGUAGE IN THE TECHNICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE WORK DURING THE
ONGOING PROCESS IN BELARUS.
IF THAT'S TRUE, THERE STILL
REMAINS DISTANT DEEP
DISAGREEMENT ABOUT THE STATUS O
THE BREAKAWAY PROVINCES IN
EASTERN UKRAINE, BUT RUSSIA DID
SAY LAST NIGHT THAT ITS MILITAR
OPERATIONS, IF THAT'S WHAT YOU
WANT TO COLLATE AND UKRAINE WAS
MOSTLY COMPLETE AND BY GOING
FORWARD IT WOULD FOCUS PRIMARIL
ON THE EASTERN PART OF THE
NATION.
THIS IS ACTUALLY A BIG SHIFT AN
MAY INDICATE THAT RUSSIA, AFTER
INFLICTING HEINOUS PAIN AND
SUFFERING ON THAT UKRAINIAN
PEOPLE, HAS NOW LIMITED ITS
GOALS IN THE UKRAINE.
NOW IF AMERICA HAD A STRONG
LEADER, A REAL PRESIDENT, HE
WOULD FIND A WAY RIGHT NOW TO
CAPITALIZE ON THESE POTENTIAL
BREAKTHROUGHS AND ENCOURAGE
EVERYONE, ALL PARTIES TO DO IT
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
THAT WOULD SAVE COUNTLESS LIVES
AND PREVENT OR SUFFERING.
INSTEAD WE HAVE JOE BIDEN WHO
COMES OFF AS KIND OF A DISTANT
OBSERVER OF ALL OF THIS.
NOT A BELIEVER OF THE FREE WORL
BRIT.
>> THEY'RE OUR NEGOTIATIONS,
DISCUSSIONS I SHOULD SAY THAT
HAVE TAKEN PLACE THAT I HAVE NO
BEEN A PART OF INCLUDING
UKRAINIANS.
HE HAD TO DISSIPATING TO SAPIR
FROM THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL AND NOW
HE HAD TO TAKE A BACK STAGE TO
LESSER POWERS IN NATO PAIR HE I
JUST WAITING FOR HIS MARCHING
ORDERS AT THIS POINT.
MEANWHILE, HE IS PREVIEWING THE
WONDERFUL FUTURE ALL OF US
AMERICANS WILL LOOK FORWARD TO
UNDER HIS WATCH BRITT.
>> WE WILL TALK ABOUT FOOD
SHORTAGES, AND IT'S GOING TO BE
REAL, THE PRICE OF THE SANCTION
IS NOT JUST IMPOSED UPON RUSSIA
IT IS IMPOSED ON AND OFF A LOT
OF COUNTRIES AS WELL INCLUDING
EUROPEAN COUNTRIES AND OUR
COUNTRY AS WELL.
THANK YOU WE ARE THE BREADBASKE
OF THE WORLD, UKRAINE AND RUSSIA
, BUT WE, THE UNITED
STATES WILL DO OUR PART BECAUSE
WE ARE THE THIRD-LARGEST
PRODUCER OF WHEAT IN THE WORLD.
>> AND AMERICAN PRESIDENT IS
SUPPOSED TO REASSURE US.
BIDEN JUST TERRIFIES US AND
DEPRESSES US.
IN CASE YOU HAVEN'T HEARD ENOUG
FROM HIM, HE WILL HAVE MORE
TOMORROW ON THE CRISIS OF FIRST
THE SAME CRISIS THAT NEVER WOUL
HAVE OCCURRED UNDER PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
>> YOU CAN BET THAT AMERICAN
TAXPAYERS WILL BE FORCED TO FOO
THE BILL ONCE AGAIN.
>> HE WILL GIVE A MAJOR ADDRESS
TOMORROW THAT WILL SPEAK TO THE
STAKES OF THIS MOMENT, THE
URGENCY OF THE CHALLENGE THAT
LIES AHEAD, WHAT THE CONFLICT I
UKRAINE MEANS FOR THE WORLD.
>> DID HE SAY MEANS FOR THE
WORLD?
NOW MOCK I HAVEN'T MET MORE
FOREIGN LEADERS THAN ANYONE
ALIVE HASN'T HAD ONE FOREIGN
POLICY SUCCESS UNDER HIS BELT.
AND LESS YOU CALL HIS
AFGHANISTAN WITHDRAWAL OF WIN
FOR AMERICA.
WE DO KNOW ONE THING, UNDER
BIDEN'S WATCH, CHIDED ALWAYS
ENDS UP WITH THE LONGER END OF
THE STICK.
THEY ARE LEARNING AND PLOTTING
AS BIDEN FLAILS AND FLOUNDERS
FROM ONE CRISIS TO THE NEXT.
EVEN WHEN HE TRIES TO BE
EMPATHETIC WITH ALL THE TRAGEDY
UNFOLDING FOR THE UKRAINIAN
PEOPLE HE SOMEHOW MANAGES TO
BOTCH IT.
>> WHEN YOU SEE A 30 -YEAR-OLD
WOMAN STANDING THERE IN FRONT O
A TANK WITH A RIFLE, TALK ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENED IN TIANANMEN
SQUARE, THAT'S TIANANMEN SQUARE
SQUARED.
>> DID HE ACTUALLY SAY THAT?
HOW PROFOUND.
WHY HASN'T HE RELEASED THE
TRANSCRIPT OF THAT BIG CALL HE
HAD A FEW WEEKS AGO WITH
PRESIDENT XI SHOULDN'T THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE KNOW WHAT WAS
SAID.
WE KNOW CHINA AND OTHER OUTLETS
SAID THAT BRIGHTON HAD AGREED T
PLAY NICE ON ALL THE ISSUES
IMPORTANT TO THIS ECP OF COURSE
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THE TRUTH IS
BECAUSE BIDEN'S PEOPLE REFUSED
TO BE TRANSPARENT ABOUT WHAT IF
ANYTHING HE OFFERED CHINA IN
RETURN FOR THEIR HELP WITH
RUSSIA.
NOT ONLY IS CHINA ACTING AS A
BACKSTOP, IT IS RIGHT NOW
EXPANDING ITS INFLUENCE AND
REACH AS AMERICAN OFFICIALS ARE
DISTRACTED IN EASTERN EUROPE.
THAT HE IS HASHING OUT THE FINA
DETAILS OF THE SECRET SECURITY
OF THE SOLOMON ISLANDS.
THE TINY ISLAND NATION
STRATEGICALLY SAID IT OFF
NORTHERN AUSTRALIA HAD NOT TOO
FROM NEW ZEALAND EITHER.
TIPPING THE BALANCE OF POWER
TOWARD CHINA AND THE INDO
PACIFIC, THAT WILL REPRESENT A
SERIOUS THREAT TO OUR ALLIES AN
FRANKLY TO U.S. INTEREST.
ONCE AGAIN, AMERICAN WEAKNESS
HAS FAR-REACHING IMPLICATIONS,
NONE OF THEM GOOD.
THERE IS NO QUESTION THAT THE
BALANCE OF SECURITY IN THE
REGION WOULD BE AFFECTED THAT
PETER JENNINGS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE STRATEGIC POLIC
INSTITUTE THINK TANK.
IT WOULD ENORMOUSLY COMPLICATE
AUSTRALIA'S ABILITY TO MOVE SUB
AND SHIPS AND AIRCRAFT ALONG TH
AUSTRALIAN EAST COAST.
THEY WILL BE WATCHED FROM THE
SOLOMON ISLANDS.
>> ONCE AGAIN, CHINA HAS OUT
MANEUVERED THE FEEBLEMINDED U.S
PRESIDENT WHO THINKS WE ARE
WORRIED ABOUT GETTING HOME TO
DELAWARE FOR THE WEEKEND THAN
THEY GEOPOLITICAL STORM CLOUDS
AHEAD.
BEYOND THE PRESIDENT HIMSELF,
CHINA KNOWS HE DOESN'T FACE ANY
OBSTACLES OR ANY REAL CALL FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY FROM MEMBER
MEMBER OF THE BIDEN CABINET
EITHER.
THEY DON'T NEED MORE LOBBYIST I
DC, THEY HAVE BIDEN'S TREASURY
SECRETARY.
>> WOULD YOU CONSIDER SANCTIONS
ON CHINA AS AN ALLY OF RUSSIA A
THIS POINT?
>> I DON'T THINK THAT IS
NECESSARY OR APPROPRIATE AT THI
POINT.
SENIOR ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS
ARE TALKING PRIVATELY AND
QUIETLY WITH CHINA TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY UNDERSTAND OUR
POSITION.
>> OH, THAT THEY UNDERSTAND IT
ALL RIGHT, WEAKNESS IS VERY EA